- Good afternoon.
Welcome to everyone.
My name is Victoria Stone-Cadena,
I am the associate director here at RITM.
As part of our mission as a center,
we are tasked with
supporting research efforts
across the university
that center around issues of race,
indigeneity, and transnational migration.
In that effort, RITM supports research
and conference attendance
for both undergraduate
and graduate students throughout the year.
We are delighted to welcome you all
for this three minute research showcase,
as we hear from Yale graduate students
who conducted research
with our support this past summer.
Each student is asked to synthesize
their research in under three minutes,
using just one slide.
While challenging, it is always exciting
to hear the highlights
of important research being
done across the campus,
which includes researchers tonight from...
Or this afternoon,
from over 11 different departments,
as you can see in the program here.
After each student presents,
we will have time for
one to two questions,
and then we'll invite the next speaker.
We invite you to join us afterwards
for some light refreshments
and conversation.
I would like to take a moment
to give a special thanks to Ryan Huynh,
who is a Woodbridge Fellow
with RITM this year
for all his work and
preparation of this event.
Likewise, I'd like to thank
the rest of the RITM team
for their support as well.
In keeping this timely,
I will now turn this over to Henriëtte.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you, Ryan and RITM for organizing,
and for giving me the opportunity
to offer you a little glimpse
of what I've been working on this summer.
On this slide,
you see an engraving by Abraham Bosse
of actors performing at the
Hôtel de Bourgogne in Paris.
It's the most prominent permanent stage
in the 1630s.
Notice how the actor's bodies
are opened up to the audience.
The way the performers are
arranged shows consideration
for stylized physicality
and the stage picture.
Notice, too, the costumes,
the different styles.
The captain with the huge ruff,
the lovers and their lavish outfits.
Materials that likely had
origins way beyond France,
testament to France's
growing colonial empire.
Finally, notice the unembellished
and small stage.
All this relates to a tradition
of traveling companies,
when costumes and props were easier
to move than sets,
and where physicality and
visuality were important
when voices didn't carry.
Significantly, this image
depicts not just characters
but real people.
The actors you see here were some
of the most celebrated
French actors of their time,
and many of them performed
not only in Paris,
but also across the country,
and as far as Belgium and the Netherlands.
For example, Julien Bedeau
and his wife, Isabel Mestivier,
led the troop of the Prince of Orange
some 10 years earlier
before this image was drawn,
bringing their performances
to the court in the Hague
and to other cities
across the Low Countries.
The performance cultures
of the Netherlands
and France were closely connected.
In the archives,
I found significant
similarities in language
and content of court orders
that gave actors permission to perform,
as well as in the size
of the playing spaces.
Furthermore, these were
actors working in Paris,
as well as across France
and the Low Countries,
bringing with them style and technique.
Thus, by studying French sources,
I was able to discover more about
what performance in the
Hague might've looked like,
and thus what the performance
of Pierre Corneille's
"Cid" could have been like
when it was performed there in 1638.
While chiefly presented as a play
about impossible love,
"The Cid" is a political adaptation
of a medieval Spanish legend;
A response to the centralization
of power in France
by Richelieu and Louis XIII,
the war with Spain,
and France's expanding colonial project.
My dissertation explores how four
of the most popular productions
of the first decade of Amsterdam
City theater transformed
as they transferred from across Europe,
and what implications that has
on an understanding of
Dutch imperial narratives
and identity formation at the time.
This semester, I am considering
the purpose and consequences
of "The Cid's" circulation.
How would audiences in The Hague,
and subsequently Amsterdam,
relate to this story of
a Spanish national hero
at a time when both France
and the Netherlands were
at war with Spain?
How could the different
local contexts have informed reception?
And finally, how might
the character reflect
a supranational, white, Christian,
European self-fashioning in opposition
to the Islamic empires
to the east and the south?
If you have any thoughts or questions,
I would love to hear from you.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Hi everybody.
All right.
So I study ancient religious texts,
especially the Hebrew Bible,
within the Religious Studies Department.
And what about that I'm most interested is
contemporary interpretive approaches
that communities develop
towards meaning and praxis.
So even more fascinating about that is
the power dynamics that come into play
in the interpretation process,
noting the fact that
the predominant interpretive approaches
and frameworks for a long time have
all been white Eurocentric.
So some of the key questions for me,
beyond what the Bible...
What is the Bible,
is how do we read it?
And thus, what other non-Western
approaches are there?
So taking a post-colonial approach,
my research explores
indigenous knowledge systems,
namely African oral culture,
literature, history,
including proverbs, riddle...
Riddles, sorry.
Story forms, novels, cultural songs,
myths, mythologies, et cetera
to explore new frameworks
that there might be
to capture African realities,
while also contributing
to the ongoing discussion
on decentering whiteness
and multi-racializing
biblical interpretation
and biblical studies.
So with support from RITM,
I head to Ghana,
a West African country
with a rich cultural heritage
and an important history colonization...
Colonialism, independence, and religion.
And my research took me
to various institutions and sites
to observe and to talk to key scholars
already doing similar work.
So to name a few,
some of the pictures you see here,
I went to the University of Ghana,
I went to the Bible Society
of Ghana, Ashesi University,
Akrofi-Christaller Institute
of Theology and Mission,
Methodist University,
Trinity Theological Seminary.
And aside from spending hours talking
to several scholars and graduate students
at these institutions,
I audited classes, visited libraries,
spent some time at various archives.
And outside of the university world,
I went to the Kwame Nkrumah Museum,
in the middle picture,
to explore Ghana's west...
Ghana and West Africa's history.
I also went to the slavery...
The Cape Coast Slave Castle
to explore Africa's history
with slavery, and
colonization, and independence,
and especially aspects of those
that intersect with my
interest in indigeneity
and newer forms, post-colonial
interpretive approaches.
Two key moments for me
among these were classes that I audited
on translation and enculturation,
and my visit to the mission archives
at Akrofi-Christaller
Institute of Theology.
I think that they opened up for me
a whole new world of interpretation
that is rooted in
European-led translation,
while also exposing me to
the potential of language
and language theory, translation theory,
for the success of my entire project.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, hi everyone.
My name is Adriana,
I'm a PhD student in sociology.
And today, I'll be sharing
with you all my project,
titled "Post Deportation Repeat Migration:
"Intent to Remigrate Among
"Recently Deported Central
American Immigrants."
And I presented my working paper
with the support of RITM this past summer.
So despite their limited
access to healthcare
and exclusion from
mainstream institutions,
Latinos in the US display
lower mortality and morbidity rates
than their native and white counterparts.
And this health advantage
is often described
as the so-called
"Hispanic health paradox,"
and it's believed to be a result
of the selection of immigrants
who migrate to and from the US.
For instance, research finds that
healthier people are
more likely to migrate,
and those who are unhealthy are
more likely to return home
to seek medical treatment,
family support, or to die.
However, changes in immigration policy
and enforcement has shaped selection
into return migration,
as immigrants can either voluntarily
or involuntarily return
home through deportation.
But despite the record number
of deportations in the past two decades,
the health status of immigrants
who return to the US
after being deported
remains largely unknown.
And this is critical to understand
because even though there are
significant legal repercussions
for attempting to return
to the US after deportation,
research continues to find
that deportees who are deported will be
more than likely to return
to the US sometime in the future.
So my study takes a step towards capturing
the complexities of immigrant health
by examining the health status of
recently deported Central
American immigrants
who intend to return to the US relative
to their peers who will stay
in their country of origin.
And I drawn data from
the survey of migration
in the southern border of Mexico,
also known as Emif Sur,
which is a cross-sectional survey
that is highly representative
of the Salvadoran, Honduran,
and Guatemalan adults
who are detained and deported
back to Central America
between 2012 and 2020.
And overall, I find that deportees
who intend to return to the US are
more likely to say that
they have poor health,
relative to their healthier peers who plan
on staying in Central America.
And I also find that deportees,
who report negative experiences
during their apprehension and detention,
are more likely to have poor health.
So these findings suggest
that the health selection...
That health selection is a complex process
that cannot offer a simple explanation
for the health outcome of Latinos.
In particular, this could be a result
of the Hispanic Health
Paradox being developed
at a different historical moment,
and it also may fall short
in explaining the health outcomes
of contemporary immigrants
in an era of mass deportation.
And as punitive immigration
policies continue
to change and deportations
continue to rise,
it's important to explicitly examine
the population movement and selection
of what I call "post-deportation
repeat migrants,"
to further understand how
they navigate life
after their deportation.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everyone.
I am Diana,
and I'm a second year
in the history PhD program.
Gonzalo Gonzalez,
the subject of the right
hand article over there,
was a working class Mexican
revolutionary and baker
who migrated to New York
City during the 1920s.
Shortly after being laid off
from his bakery job in 1929,
he became an active member
of the Communist Party's Latina chapter
in New York.
In the summer of 1930,
he was assassinated by the NYPD
at a march that protested the death
of a black comrade who
had also been killed
by the police.
Around the time that
Gonzalo was assassinated,
he was one of over 4,000 Mexicans living
in New York City.
Mexicans represented
less than five percent
of the city's Latina population,
a relatively smaller percentage compared
to that of other ethnic groups
from Latin America and the Caribbean.
However, the life and legacy
of Gonzalez demonstrate
that Mexicans held visible
and meaningful roles
in the city's labor and leftist movements
of the post-World War I era.
While Gonzalez was one of
the more remarkable organizers
in the city,
hundreds of other working
class Mexican migrants were
also active members in leftist labor
and political organizations.
Gonzalez's narrative
guides my current research
on radical Mexican political culture
in post-World War I New York.
Over the summer, I became interested
in taking a more trans-local approach
by identifying connections or networks
that may have been established
between leftist Latina or Mexican chapters
in New York City,
and the Mexican Communist
Party, or the MCP.
With support from RITM,
I spent some time in Mexico City visiting
El Centro de Estudios del
Movimiento Obrero y Socialista.
During my archival visits,
I sorted through the
periodicals of El Machete,
which was the MCPs official newspaper
between 1924 to 1938.
I came across a handful of articles
that confirmed an ongoing dialogue
between Mexican leftists
in New York and Mexico.
In some instances,
Mexican New Yorkers
invited leaders of the MCP
to deliver speeches and conventions.
In other occasions,
Mexican communists in New York organized
mutual aid events aimed
at fundraising for El Machete,
as shown in the bottom left.
Perhaps the most exciting moment
of transnational leftist encounters
that I came across was
when Hernán Laborde,
director of El Machete,
attended a commemoration event in 1936,
honoring the six year anniversary
of Gonzalez's death,
discussed on the right hand article.
The periodicals that I
came across generated
important questions for my research.
For example, "to what extent did these
"ongoing trans-local encounters shape
"radical leftist movements
"in New York City and Mexico City?
"What were the contours of
this dialectical process?"
I look forward to
addressing these questions
in my ongoing social history research
on Gonzalez and the lives
of working class Mexicans
in post-World War I, New York.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, hi everyone.
I'm Sophia, fourth year
in sociology and AfAm.
The title of my project is
"How Youth Creates Race
in the 21st Century."
Really, it's an attempt
to look differently
at the increased vulnerability
that young black people
and others of color face
in the wake of both 2020s racial violence
and the neglect of young people
in the national response to COVID-19.
This comes especially as conflict arises
between racial and
youth-related public desire.
So for example, the premature return
to unsafe school conditions,
justified by keeping afloat minority
and adolescent development,
but then condemning the
teaching of black history
with claims of being
unsuitable for children.
In light of these tensions,
I explore how black youth
in particular manage
these ideological conflicts
between constructions of race and youth,
and the impact of that relationship
on policy and sense of self.
So this slide today represents two
of three parts to the project.
The first is archivally tracing
what I see as this
relationship historically;
How do ideas about race infuse ideas
about what it means to be young?
So I trace the rise of race science
and its view on adolescent development,
how fears of peer pressure intersected
with fears of school integration,
things like that.
And then, the second part is interviews
with young black people.
So I used my RTM funding
to compensate them,
so I don't have pictures
of them obviously.
But I wanted to talk about one shift
that I found between
these 20th century management tactics
that I found in the archives
and what I'm noticing
now in my interviewees,
because the 21st century "Trayvon
Generation," so to speak,
is a coming-of-age process
that's actually characterized by
the ubiquity of racial violence online.
So youth of color have always held
a voice in their communities
and networked with each other
over racial issues through media,
and how they spoke about
these racial issues was tied
to ideas about youth.
So this poem on the right was written
by a 15 year old after World War II
and racial campaigns around that.
She was writing in the junior section
of the Chicago Defender,
a black newspaper.
This picture in the middle was
a panel of black teens
who was invited to speak
on a TV show about youth delinquency
and its racial associations in 1965,
so around different racial riots.
But now, during events of racial violence,
the actual form of communication
or media is appearing
to have an increased impact
on the approach to coming-of-age
in comparison to the event itself, right?
So the social media accounts
that you make as an
adolescent rite of passage,
that cultivate your friendships and so on.
So this quote at the bottom comes
from an interviewee who was talking
about a police brutality incident
that happened the same
weekend as his prom,
and how his Twitter feed was
really in clutter because
of the different types
of posts that were being shared.
And he says, "It's like everyone's
"on Twitter sharing pictures of prom,
"and I'm here on Twitter sharing pictures
"of a dead person.
"They're like, "But this is our youth."
"Like okay, but this is mine."
So I'm really just interested in knowing
how we can pay better attention
to ideals about what constitutes youth,
how might ideas of race be informing that,
and ways we might not be noticing
that could be causing
strife and overwhelm.
'Cause I really think knowing more
about how these relations are...
Relationships are produced
can kind of give us
another angle to dismantle them from.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everyone.
I have notes but I don't
really like reading from notes,
so I'm gonna try to
just do it from memory.
So Latinx folks here
in the United States are the rapid...
Most rapid growing group
to convert to Islam.
And I'm focusing on Mexico specifically.
Pretty much a lot of the major cities
in Mexico have mosques and musallas,
which are like small prayer rooms.
But what I was fascinated by, to hear,
was that in Chiapas,
San Cristóbal de las Casas, Chiapas,
in a rural area, there's
an indigenous group,
Tzotzil Mayans, that were
rapidly converting to Islam,
and that really captured my attention.
So there are roughly about 400
or 500 Tzotzil indigenous people
who converted to Islam
in the year 1995.
So from 1995 to present,
there's roughly about 400 to 500 Muslims.
They live in a majority Catholic area.
Many of them were either Catholic
or evangelical Christians
before they converted to Islam.
So my question was,
"What led this specific community
"to convert to Islam?
"Living in a rural part of Mexico
"where Catholicism is
the mainstream religion,
"what attracted them to Islam?"
And also, the peculiar
thing about this group is
they converted across a span
of three generations
and within one family.
And so, that was
interesting to me as well.
And so when I visited
Chiapas over the summer,
I was able to conduct roughly
about 30 oral interviews,
and I was able to live alongside
a lot of the community members there,
'cause there's five different
Muslim communities there
and so I was able to visit each one.
And so, how did Islam come to Chiapas?
A Spanish Muslim by the name
of Nafia came to Spain...
From Spain to Mexico in 1994,
to Chiapas specifically.
And he wanted to convert Comandante Marcos
and the Zapatistas.
So he's a revolutionary himself,
so he's like, "I wanna combine
"this revolution and Islam
"and join forces."
Well, Comandante Marcos wasn't having it.
So then, he went to other Zapatistas
and he was successful in converting them.
And so, actually, Mohammed Amin,
who was a Zapatista,
he was the first to convert to Islam.
So that's another question
that I was asking,
connecting Zapatismo and
that revolutionary spirit,
was there like a
connection to Islam there?
I found that there was.
I mean, I don't have a lot
of time to get into it,
but that's one of the questions
I wanna further explore.
The main reason reason I gathered
why people converted to Islam was
that they were really attracted
to the fact that it didn't seem
so much as like a religion to them.
They said they didn't feel like they had
to adhere to rules and strictness,
it was more of like a way of life
and it was monotheistic.
Here in the photo that
I have on the screen,
this is a photo of four women on Eid,
which is a Muslim religious holiday.
And as you can see,
they're dressed in their
traditional Tzotzil clothing,
and while they're wearing
their hijabs/rebozos,
I was really interested in
the connection between the hijab
and if they found that it
was foreign, or what...
Like, how did they feel living in Mexico
and observing the hijab.
And they said that basically
their mothers and their
grandmothers wore rebozos,
some of them wore rebozos
when they were younger.
And so, wearing the hijab didn't seem
something like too far off
or foreign to them.
And it's kind of cool
'cause I don't think in this picture,
but some of them wear their
traditional rebozos still
as their hijabs.
And so...
Yeah, and so another...
When I interviewed a Muslim leader there
by the name of Ibrahim,
I asked him if there was a connection
to indigeneity and Islam,
and he said that his grandfather
actually converted to Islam
because he found a lot of similarities
with the religion of Islam
to his indigenous roots.
Just to give you one example is
the prostration that Muslims perform
during their five daily prayers.
He said that his grandfather was
already performing some of those
similar prostrations during
his prayers following
his indigenous faith.
And so, it resonated with his grandfather,
and that's how him and his
whole entire family converted to Islam.
And what I found most interesting
during my research trip was to see
how Zapatista revolutionaries
were converting to Islam,
but also how women found
a lot of, I'm quoting...
"Liberation," "freedom."
And I mean, when I heard them...
It's their words, not mine,
but when I heard them say that,
it was interesting to me
because they said the outside world
of Mexico sees them as oppressed,
but they're like, "We actually feel like
"we're not oppressed at all."
And so, what I hope to do
on my next trip is Omar,
who's a form former Zapatista,
he has a room full of old
newspaper clippings and articles,
and they're all like...
I mean, they're filled up to here
and I didn't have enough time
to go through all of them,
but I'm curious to just learn more
about the Zapatistas
and their conversions to Islam,
and also just about this
indigenous community
that is continuing to...
Islam is growing within
such a small place like
San Cristóbal de las Casas.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everyone, my name is Cristian.
I'm sixth year PhD in history.
So yeah, this summer,
I spent some time
consulting some archives,
specifically the Standard
Food Company Archives
in New Orleans, in Tulane,
and the (indistinct)
Collections in Princeton.
So yeah, that's just the quote that you...
I will translate in a few,
but I wanted to speak more broadly
about another event.
In the summer of 1983,
James Carney, later known as Padre Lupe,
a US Jesuit priest turned guerilla,
left a Nicaraguan border village
to Olancho, Honduras,
near the Patuca River,
with a 96 men gorilla group called
the Central American
Revolutionary Workers Party, PRTC,
led by former Dr. Jose Maria Reyes Mata,
who was once a friend of Che Guevara.
A few weeks later, around mid-September,
Padre Lupe and most of
his comrades were captured
and summarily executed by
the CIA-trained Honduran
Special Forces Command, or SFC.
And so, whether that's...
The death of most of
the Honduran members
didn't get much attention.
US and Honduran...
The death of Padre Lupe, a US citizen,
certainly caught the attention.
Multiple accounts of his
death still remain...
Sorry.
While the deaths of
the Honduran members didn't get attention,
the death of Lupe did,
and the Honduran authorities were keen
on suppressing the details
of the death of Padre Lupe
because he was a US citizen.
Multiple accounts of his
death remained plausible.
One being he was shot
with a 45 caliber pistol
along with Reyes Mata,
another one saying that
he died by malaria,
another one decapitated,
another one tortured to death,
another one thrown out from a helicopter.
However, when the bodies of
the other insurgents washed out
onto the riverbanks of the Patuca River,
the authorities remained silent,
all while claiming that he died
from starvation and illness.
The precise fate of Padre Lupe
remains unknown to this day.
Whether claimed by the unpredictable wrath
of nature and disease,
or by the covert designs
of a CIA-trained operations,
his story remains largely untold,
shrouded in layers of
intrigue and silence.
It's a silence that speaks volumes
about the very nature
of Honduran (indistinct)
of the Cold War narratives.
His hidden demise mirrors
the paradox of Honduras itself;
Central to US Cold War agendas
yet often relegated to
a footnote of history.
While its terrain in politics were
long deemed invaluable for US interest,
its true role, much like Padre
Lupe's death, went unnoticed,
buried under the weight
of the larger central
American revolutions.
As Padre Lupe's fate remains
an unsolved mystery,
so does the question
"how has a nation so
integral been overlooked
"in US Cold War history?"
That's the story of Honduras
and how it's lacked a lot
of historical production.
But within that, a bigger
question that I had is
how you lose stories like these,
of Santo Centeno Garcia,
who was a black garifuna communist
and organizer in the 1950s,
who was part of the larger labor movements
in the 1950s,
was also part of a anti-racist
organization called
the Abraham Lincoln Culture Society.
And so, when the product of this lack
of historical production has
also silenced these histories
of working people,
working indigenous people,
but also working black people in Honduras.
So yeah, that's my intro into that.
My dissertation is obviously
much more complicated.
But yeah, that's what I wanted
to leave everyone with,
and thank you.
Take questions.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, hi everyone.
I'm Junhan, a second year master student
who is focused on
environmental anthropology
at School of Environment.
My research examined the
indigenous environmentalism
on the Tibetan plateau in China.
My research interest comes from
a contradictory observation
when I work with Tibetan
conservation NGOs.
And this is me,
this is my main interlocutor.
And first, the homogeneous interpretation
of Tibetan environmentalism
by Chinese conservationists
simply as "Tibetan people believes
"in sacred mountains and lakes."
And then, the very diverse
practices, discourses,
of Tibetan conservation NGOs.
Each NGO's articulations about why
and how we should protect
nature is very different.
This made me curious about one question,
how some critical things,
such as indigeneity, politics, science,
are articulated in these
NGOs conservation projects,
and what we can learn about
human nature coexistence
from this complex landscape.
So this summer, I went
back to Tibetan Plateau
and stayed for nearly three months
in four NGOs.
And three of them were
led by Buddhist monks
and one was led by Tibetan herder.
It was quite an enjoyable journey.
I had a chance to visit some old friends,
and met many new faces
in these NGOs and
conservation conferences.
I did interviews with these NGOs leaders,
like these monks,
and also did participant observation
in raptor monitoring, ecotourism,
and other conservation projects.
Three of my primary founding
findings can be summarized as,
first, the adaptability of indigeneity
in Tibetan conservation.
It very much relies on
environmental leaders'
continuous translation between
Han Chinese and Tibetan,
science, and tradition, and others.
Second, a vital landscape
of Tibetan environmentalism
where diverse practices
and discourse coexist
through similar cultural structure
but very different sociopolitical context,
and also personal
propositions of these leaders.
Third, general (indistinct) ,
conservation knowledge
of people or nature,
co-produced by these NGOs.
It might be the next stages
of human nature coexistence for us,
while the current is more
likely people and nature.
In short, I hope the result of
this research can making voice
for indigenous people
on the Tibetan plateau,
and also provide alternatives
to the global conservation.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everybody.
I'm Alan, a fourth year PhD student
in the history of architecture program.
My dissertation examines
the contested logics
of urban development on
the Texas-Mexico border
in the latter half of the 20th century,
and focuses on the role
of design professionals,
namely architects, engineers,
and urban planners,
and the roles they played in
the dynamics of the region's
interstate political economy.
Amid post-war reconstruction
and a global economic development,
the design professions established
newfound footholds in society
by leveraging technical knowledge
into innovative forms
of managerial expertise.
With its expertise in hand,
the design of the built environment became
an essential aspect of
the function of government
and access to an
interconnected global economy.
With the assistance of RITM,
I was able to conduct two weeks
of archival research at
the University of Texas' Benson
Latin American collection,
Alexander Architectural Archives.
Specifically, the
organizations I was looking
at were the American Friend
Service Committee Collections,
the Rodman C Rockefeller Mexico-US
Business Committee files,
as well as the collection
of the American Planning Association,
and a planning professor
named Hugo Leipziger,
who was one of the founders
of UT's planning school.
The archives, as we
can see from the image,
presented a kaleidoscopic vision
of what the US-Mexico was imagined to be
between the years in 1960 and 1990.
On one end of the spectrum,
we see this vision includes
the aspiration of modernist architects
and local chambers of commerce projecting
a certain image of modernity
and prosperity into
the border's landscape.
And on the other,
we find what could be considered
a certain form of urban informality
that presupposes a economic structure
that requires a certain underclass.
As border industrialization
attracted inhabitants
and capital from both
nations and elsewhere,
urban populations and their
economic impacts ballooned
well beyond the scope devised
by mid-century planners.
As I see it,
urban informality itself is
the dialectical foil
to modernist development on the border.
And if anything,
we have to consider
these two aspects of the built environment
in tension with each other.
These disjunctures that we're seeing here
up on the screen beg the question of,
"Do architects and planners
consider themselves
"woefully ignorant of the effects
"of their architectural impact
"or can we consider this
"a dereliction of professional duties
"and civic engagement?"
But any questions?
(audience applauding)
- Okay.
Hi everybody, my name is Roy, Roy Celaire,
I am a second year PhD...
Sorry, that's a lie.
I'm a third year PhD
student in anthropology.
So my research is on black
queer life in the UK.
Also, on the weekend,
Friday and Saturday,
there is something going on
which I'm gonna just talk about,
so if you could pass that along.
But my research is on
black queer life in the UK,
but this summer with RITM,
as well as having money for my research,
I also was part of another project,
and it's called InBEST,
so Intersectional Black European Studies.
So this is Berlin Cathedral
and that's obviously me.
And so, part of this project
and what you're gonna see from
the little postcard there is
basically Professor Fatima El-Tayeb,
who's part of RITM,
or Ethnicity, Race, and Migration.
She's part of a group in Germany
of black women, black feminists,
who are essentially trying to digitize
and archive a lot of different media.
So for example, magazines, posters.
So essentially, archiving
black feminist literature
and different kind of paraphernalia, even,
pertaining to black women, lesbians,
black people more broadly.
And so what myself and other fellows did,
we went down to Berlin
and stayed there for three weeks,
and we were part of the project of trying
to digitize a lot of
the different magazines
that came into our hands.
And we went to different places
and different spaces to connect
with black Germans.
So for example, we went
to a place called EOTO,
which stands for "each one teach one."
And so, essentially,
it was a learning experience
where we got to learn more about Germany,
or black Germany particularly.
And in terms of how this relates
to my own research,
it was very fascinating to hear
the stories and experiences
of black Germans,
and how they were similar
and different to the
black British context.
And so, if one example
that one of the German...
Afro-German people that
we interacted with,
she would mention that in Germany,
people would say to her,
"Oh, your German is so good.
"How can you speak such a good German?"
And she'll say, "well, I'm from here.
"I was born here."
And the refrain will always be,
"But where you really from?"
And so, that was something
that was definitely
something I connect to,
'cause in the UK,
there has been a black population there
for a very long time,
but often our connection to
the nation is denied and repudiated.
so there's a lot of
different connections there
that I can relate to.
But the project more broadly is
something that is gonna continue.
And on Friday and Saturday,
as you can see from the poster
that's going around,
and you can turn it around
as well to stuff at the back
to show you who's coming.
But yeah, on Friday, you
are all welcome to come,
and we will be having different
discussions and talks,
and you're gonna have different people,
different black scholars
and activists from Europe,
coming to speak about their work
and black European studies.
And for example, Gloria Wekker,
who's quite well known,
she's a black Dutch
feminist anthropologist
who'll be there.
And there'll be many other people as well.
And I'll be there as well.
But that was a quick little snapshot
of what I was doing
in the summer in Berlin, so yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Hi everyone, my name is Zoe Lee-Park.
I study the Normative Theory
of Environmental Justice.
What should environmental
justice look like?
The environmental justice movement,
if you don't know what it is,
it's the poor people of color movement
for clean and safe environments for all.
Centuries and decades of
white supremacy have resulted
in many of these communities living
in places that are very
toxic, very polluted.
And in my review of the literature,
I found that there's
still a real disconnect
between scholarly normative arguments
and then the grassroots arguments
that I was hearing in
my own work off campus.
And so, through my thesis,
I sought to bridge this kind of gap.
So I pursued a 14 week
embedded ethnography with two
different environmental justice
organizations in California.
I am from California,
these are communities I really love.
So during those 14
weeks I was volunteering
and really learning
through that volunteering.
And so, for the first
seven weeks of summer,
I was at Green Action for Health
and Environmental Justice.
They're based in San Francisco.
And then, for the second
seven weeks of summer,
I was at the Central Coast Alliance United
for a Sustainable Economy,
or CAUSE for short.
And CAUSE asked for my support
at the Santa Maria office.
Santa Maria is a predominantly
farm working community.
And so, through my volunteering,
I learned from my communities
what environmental justice
and responsibilities should include.
And I adopted approaches
from grounded normative theory.
Grounded normative theory is outlined
by Professor Brooke Ackerly.
And so, I sought to use a variety
of different empirical methods,
developing ideas recursively,
being inclusive of different ways
of knowing in my communities,
and then re-articulating these findings
in ways back to my communities
that were helpful to them.
And so, I organized focus groups,
which were smaller discussions
with my community members,
and organized presentation
feedback sessions
where I asked my communities for feedback
on what I was finding.
I also attended public meetings
and I conducted several interviews.
And I hired three research assistants,
three really brilliant young women
from my communities
who supported the project tremendously.
And so, the goal for the thesis is
to develop normative theories rooted
in the arguments of my community members
to really help them shape policy
and society to towards their visions.
And so now, this semester back at Yale,
I am learning how to analyze
my ethnographic field notes.
And as I'm analyzing my field notes,
I'm combining those findings
with my two other methods,
which is content analysis
on pieces published
by these organizations,
and then also historical analysis
on the histories of my communities;
How those different histories have shaped
the normative of arguments they're making.
And in the spring of 2024,
I'm gonna be returning to California
to share the findings of this study
wherever my community
members want me to share.
Local council meetings
have come up as a big one.
And I'm really grateful to the center
for all of the ongoing support,
especially it enabled me to hire
a third research assistant.
Really brilliant...
Really brilliant young person.
And so yeah, thankful for all the support.
(audience applauding)